what's up guys bang bang it is lunch
money time or while she's trying to get
rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here with the
beautiful intelligent pelina ivalova
marinova pompano p-i-m-p
she got a georgia shirt on but we're not
going to comment about it go gators
all right don't forget that block fight
is now sponsored by
lunch money is not sponsored by block
five block five sponsored by lunch money
one day it will be but lunch money is
sponsored by block five make sure you go
and get a blackfy account go to
blockfy.com
blockfight.com pomp blockfy.com
pomp i'm gonna make it so that you guys
have nightmares and in your dreams i'm
saying
blockfi.com go get an account
you can earn up to 8.6 apy in their
interest bearing account
i'm an investor i'm a happy user you
will be to go to buffy.com
what's up what is up is bang bang
what is up is that today is inauguration
day and president-elect joe biden will
be sworn
in as the next president of the united
states guys my family in bulgaria is
telling me there is coverage there
non-stop all day i was like
what do you guys care but i guess they
care yeah i mean look whether you
like joe biden whether you like donald
trump whether you hate both of them you
like both of them
uh or you think the alien should be the
president uh this is the beauty of
democracy
is that uh people vote and there are
changes in political parties and we have
a democratic process
and so great let's get it going
hopefully there's
no violence there's no bad things get it
going everyone chill out today
let's get this uh you know over with in
terms of just
no bad [ __ ] happening today but fingers
crossed i hope so
and uh it'd be cool to see this happen
and
a message from lunch money on
inauguration day be kind to your friends
yes that's very true all right next okay
uh
one second oh god okay leon cooperman
sees euphoria in parts of the market
says he's skeptical
on long-term outlook who is leon
cooperman first of all
uh he's a billionaire investor uh
leon cooperman is uh right
about euphoria leon cooperman is wrong
about the long-term outlook
so yes how do you know because there's
euphoria but
if you look out 10 years asset prices
will be higher in 10 years than they are
today
of course they will be because they're
literally going to keep deep share and
keep devaluing the dollar god i feel
like inflation is my theme of 2021
well it's because they started in 2020
and they're going to accelerate in 2021
but so he's right look obviously there's
a lot of euphoria in
various markets across the uh um across
the financial system
but i think people just have to remember
that if you are trying to day trade if
you were trying to buy an asset today
and sell it for more tomorrow
you have to be really really careful and
you probably shouldn't do that because
it is hard to time markets it's hard to
do that
but if you are a long-term investor and
you say i'm going to buy an asset today
and i'm going to hold it for as long as
i possibly can
then you're probably going to be okay if
you just dollar cost average into your
portfolio
and you simply say whatever i buy today
i'm not going to sell for 20 years
then it doesn't matter what price you
buy today because the way that the
dollar is devalued the asset prices will
go up over a long time
investors win losers save don't be a
loser
make sure you're investing autonomous
vehicle company
cruz just raised two billion dollars in
new equity
funding around whatever that has pushed
its valuation up to 30 billion
and guess who's an investor microsoft
microsoft
why is microsoft an investor well
because microsoft is a technology
company and microsoft would love to get
access to the data
and would probably like to partner with
cruz and also i'm assuming that
microsoft would love if cruz used
microsoft's computing infrastructure
to run all of their machine learning
computer vision and other types of
advanced computing
technology crews will be able to lock in
lower prices for cloud services and
microsoft will be able to test some of
its bleeding edge systems that can
handle workloads needed to bring machine
learning and robots
robotics like autonomous vehicles to
life at scale
it's almost like don't don't be dancing
like that it's almost like
it's almost like i just said that i told
you that that was gonna be one of the
reasons
did i just mansplain you yeah that's
fine no problem okay
alibaba founder jack ma he's alive
he's alive i told you he was alive
he appeared for the first time since the
crackdown on his tech
empire where where do you show up he has
emerged out of the spotlight
he in a video posted on chinese social
media
ma addressed rural teachers as part of
one of his charity foundations
initiatives
the stock went up eight percent just
because he actually was seen
like how crazy is that alibaba stock
went up eight percent because they were
like jack ma still alive
wild well we knew he was alive he said
guys i'm just taking no he didn't say
that somebody else said it
and how how do we know that that video
wasn't done before
because this is an annual event
look by the way remember capitalism is
amazing democracy is amazing
freedom of speech is amazing the fact
that there is literally
one of the richest men in the world who
people thought disappeared
you know what i freaking love what can
we take a moment to appreciate freedom
of speech
i just love it okay
hey girl damn hi you ain't gotta be
whistling at me like that
go ahead you are whistling at her now
she whistling at me you just couldn't
see i'm like a ventriloquist
you don't know oh my god guys guys he
says especially
an espresso but today i heard him say
what is the word you said on the phone
parapasou i was like yeah
how do you know that because i'm
intelligent
i have a command of the american okay so
how do you call the thing that you drink
espresso oh wow how do you say the word
when you mean very
especially wow he's trying really hard
guys
tomorrow he's gonna be back with the egg
especially okay
um janet yellen
says cryptocurrencies are a concern
in terrorist finance
jenny yellen is confused janet yellen
forgot
that the us dollar is the choice
currency of money launderers drug
dealers and criminals around the world
janet yellen forgot that the major banks
in the global financial system wanted
more money
last year two trillion dollars
then the entire crypto market cap times
two oh i think crazy you're worried
about people using
crypto for money laundering how about
you worry about the bank's money
laundering how much you worry about the
dollar for money laundry how you worry
about the dollar for
terrorist financing come on yeah i'd say
dropped off
freaking i don't even want to say it but
they dropped off billions of dollars
they ended up going to fund terrorist
activities
y'all can go google that too it's part
of a prisoner exchange
facts it's true
google it okay the united states put put
dollars on a pallet
and they dropped it off somewhere i
ain't gonna say what country but y'all
can google it you guys are smart okay
part of a prisoner exchange you're
telling people to google it and yet
you're saying more details i'm giving
them
enough details for the good googlers to
find it
okay ready crypto by the way just hold
on let me give it one piece of
information because this is important
uh it was estimated that last year there
was over two trillion dollars of uh
money laundering in the us dollar
but it was seen that last year less than
point four percent of all crypto trade
or all bitcoin transactions were
deemed for illicit activity 0.4
40 basis points that's it this is
literally what they are saying
is factually inaccurate go ahead
it's ask lunch money time hashtag ask lm
in the comments below jerry b jerry
jerry
first i want to welcome you two to miami
do you know that jerry maguire from uh
uh what anything to do with jerry
because yeah jerry maguire do you know
that movie
yes where he's like show me the money
go ahead so jb it's great i'm losing my
voice
my question for you is let's say the
money printing continues our currency
gets debased to the point of
hyperinflation and bitcoin blasts into
another galaxy
what does the usd of bitcoin value even
mean when prices of goods are extremely
high
is this just the way to weather the
inflation storm
the dollar value doesn't matter today
that's the whole thing
i've switched my mindset i don't measure
my wealth in dollars
i measure my wealth in bitcoin and
everything that i buy
will tell you when we're like oh we have
to go buy something i literally like
no we don't no we don't that's x amount
of bitcoin
uh-uh we ain't doing that and it changes
the way you think
so what i suggest you do is sit down
and say here's what my net worth is in
dollars okay this is what my net worth
is in bitcoin and every time you go to
make a purchase
you should think how many satoshi's am i
about to spend
and if you do that my guess is you will
stop spending money
real fast because you'll start to
realize you're financially incentivized
to spend the dollar because it will get
devalued over time
but you are incentivized to hold bitcoin
because it will appreciate in value over
time your purchasing power
so one btc equals one btc ain't nobody
out here talking about
the dollars super volatile but the
dollar is losing a lot of its purchase
power
over 20 percent of all dollars in
circulation were printed in the last 12
months
so don't worry about the us dollar price
just accumulate bitcoin
okay juan campos oceana
juan campos oceana my girlfriend
my girlfriend and i watched the show
together from the uk and we were
wondering
how did you guys meet so
we did a whole video condensed version
condensed version
is um on twitter in 2016 when i had more
twitter followers than our friend here
facts we got coffee she was a reporter
and i was trying to get some press
coverage for one of our companies and he
ain't get no press coverage i get no
press coverage but i got a wife what up
who won that one hey all right
thank you guys and we will see you
tomorrow
who won that one okay i was gonna let
that one marinate for a second that's
right i didn't get no press cards but i
got a wife
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends